Mike Florio pro football talk live
co-host NBC football night in America
and Mike joins us now Mike the timing of
this this civil suit against Antonio
Brown what do you make of that well I
mean there's a little bit strange that
the lawsuit gets filed the same day that
he's announced as members of doing the
Patriots now it's apparently within the
applicable statute of limitations but
you just have to wonder strategically
and there's always a strategy when the
lawyers are involved as to where you
file suit when you file how you file
suit how you leaked it to the media how
you present it everything if there isn't
a strategy there should be a strategy
but it is strange to think that this
thing was dropped on the same day he
officially became a patriot because I
have a feeling that if the Patriots had
known about this complication they
probably don't rush into the
relationship and maybe they only could
pursue it at all until they get a chance
to fully understand what's going on here
now everyone on the fly is having to
figure out exactly what the situation is
I helped me with this I was told two
things here about 20 minutes ago that
Antonio Browns accuser has passed a
lie-detector test and that she's only
asking for $75,000 and so it doesn't
feel like it's a money grad that I think
people's reaction to civil suit it's a
money grab do you know if those two
stories are correct anytime I hear
$75,000 Dan that gets me thinking that
maybe someone has misinterpreted the
clause at the bottom of the complaint
that it sets forth what the person wants
she's filed in federal court she's a
resident Tennessee he's a resident of
Florida to get federal jurisdiction you
have to be seeking an amount in excess
of $75,000 so I need to go look at the
actual lawsuit itself at the bottom to
see what it says it's called the prayer
for relief my guess would be and then
look she's got to be asking from once
those five thousand dollars or she can't
keep the case in federal court so okay
it's it's unusual there are strategic
reasons for limiting yourself to 75
thousand dollars if you want to stay in
state court but she's filed in federal
court you have to be above 75 thousand I
don't anything about a lie-detector test
be sure overly it's going to
down to a lie-detector test this one
doesn't get settled the lie-detector
test is a jury and a jury is going to
hear her story and a jury is going to
hear his story and the jury's going to
decide who's telling the truth
regardless of what the truth is and
there are plenty of people who are good
liars and there are plenty of people who
are bad truth tellers and when you let
that go forward when you let that
process play out unless there is
independent evidence that refutes or
corroborates her claims it comes down to
what he said and what she said and
whoever the better witness is the one
who's going to prevail how long can
something like this take in the court
system it can take months it can take
years there there there are procedures
to move these things along but the civil
justice systems is up very quickly
you've got the same judges who have to
handle criminal cases these judges are
on salary they don't get paid by the
case and you know they they they can
they can take really two three years by
the time it's all said and done now what
the NFL does with it's a different issue
but the civil case itself if it goes all
the way through to a trial it could be
2021 by the time that the the jury is
picked and the testimony begins what do
you think the conversation is at the NFL
home office right now well what they
need to do is they need to start their
investigative process and see what a big
flaws down with the NFL's in-house
justice system they don't have subpoena
power so you can't force people to talk
to you but in this case you've got a
plaintiff
you've got an alleged victim who has
said via her lawyer she's willing to
cooperate with the NFL so the lawsuits
online you find the lawyers name you
call him up and we'd like to talk to
your client we'd like to do it as soon
as possible
they do that I look into any other
evidence that they may need to follow up
on after talking to huh and then they
scheduled a meeting with Antonio Brown
and it can go fairly quickly I saw there
was a report from work-basket of
Washington Post that the NFL will
consider putting him on the Commissioner
exempt list and that's one of the tools
available the NFL if they decide based
upon the preliminary investigation if
there's reason to think that there was a
violation and if there's a violation
here series violation to rate this isn't
know one of it not not to demeanor I was
no domestic violence there's a
fundamental difference between some of
the things we've seen guys get suspended
for
and a rape if they think there's reason
to believe it's something like that
happens then they they almost have to
put him on the Commissioner exempt list
while they continue with their
investigation but they she's ready to
cooperate and I think the sooner they
get started on this the student NFL gets
to the point where they figure out
exactly what Peter did Catherine do you
think Antonio Brown plays against Miami
this weekend well you know I'm
understanding is it's up to him from the
standpoint of how quickly he learns the
offense what he does in practice how
quickly he earns the trust of Tom Brady
and how does this extra factor one wait
I'm talking about the the whole night
yeah yeah I I don't think the NFL is
going to talk to her this week I just
think it's only Wednesday it's too much
to have it all happen by Sunday and I
don't think the NFL is going to have a
basis for putting him on the
commissioner exempt list without talking
about her so they don't talk to her this
week I don't think he will be on the
commissioner exempt list come Sunday
that entire mechanism is there to let
the NFL get out of a hot kitchen right
and the NFL doesn't believe it's
disciplinary okay the guys still getting
paid what does it hurt him he's on the
commissioner exempt list he's on paid
leave and if they feel like this is too
big of a story if it doesn't die down I
can see somebody making that decision
not because of the evidence that they
have or don't have but because they
think it's probably best for the game to
not have a Antonio Brown out of the
focal point of discussion going into
week two Cleveland Browns situation with
Odell Beckham I know it may be not a big
deal but because it's obj it's a bigger
deal why didn't the officials just say
to him you can't wear the watch in the
game you you wore during warmups like
what were they they're always looking at
uniforms so how did somebody miss this
watch on Odell Beckham and why did they
allow him to wear it in the game well
I'm assuming they didn't notice it you
know guys wear wristbands all the time
and and it may have just been something
that just that just wasn't noticed by
anyone they've got employees who check
uniforms for compliance before the game
I don't know why he was allowed to wear
the thing in the game and at some point
that's the NFL was going to say can't
cross the thick white stripe and go out
on field unless you take this thing off
and I
I don't I don't get it I wanted to get
off my long type of a guy here but just
take off the watch I mean the same
people who were saying Tonio brown just
wear an approved helmet just take the
watch off why do you need to wear the
watch you don't know what time it is
you're Juran's you're not late for your
plane it's not leaving it till the rest
of the team is there I just don't
understand it and the thing about obj my
mother's a player and I do think he did
son fairly criticized an that he commits
so many unforced errors he just doesn't
you know he wants the attention but he
doesn't want that thing that goes along
with the attention which is scrutiny he
wants attention on his own terms and it
doesn't work that way and yeah cool he
wants to look if he's at this watch it
was expensive you don't need to be
wearing it if the NFL told you not to
wear it just take the good thing off
where it actually didn't well he wanted
everybody to notice it and he got what
he wanted
now if you're the NFL you say all right
you slip this one by the goalie here
we're gonna we're gonna keep an eye on
you here and you can't wear it and if
you do because he probably whatever the
fine is but it is this something where
it's just a uniform violation and it's
it's a standard fine or is this a safety
violation well they're claiming it's a
safety violation because it's a hard
object now never mind the fact that
every player on the field is wearing a
hard object called a helmet at least
there's a reason for having a helmet and
that was a point he made about knee
braces
hey guys are wearing knee braces they're
hard plastic and metal yep there's a
reason for wearing them there's no
reason to have a watch on and at some
point you just have to relent and I
really do think the way the NFL handles
its uniform violations the plant the
fines get higher and higher and
eventually they will tell you you cannot
play if you refuse to take that watch
off and and I can't imagine at that
point I'm refusing to take the watch off
but now after everything we've seen
Antonio Brown last month through the
hell do anymore Mike great to talk to
you thank you we appreciate your time
that's Mike Florio pro football talk
live co-host with Chris Sims and of
course a member of NBC football night in
America for more Dan Patrick show tune
in to audience Channel 239 on DirecTV
a stream for free on BR live or download
the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]